je pense que beaucoup d'entre nous pensent que ce virus corona
est un peu exagéré
[Musique]
absolument rien des bénévoles
tout ce que
vous contribuez en tant que sain coordonné
[Musique]
avez-vous obtenu un cacao
nous faisons toujours du porte-à-porte nous '  Nous
faisons toujours du téléphone, nous
mettons toujours des panneaux indiquant que nous
ne faisons rien de vraiment
différent de ce que nous faisions il y a
quatre ans, euh, nous sommes très,
euh, conscients du fait que, euh, c'est
là-bas, mais euh, nous
prenons chacun nos propres précautions.
si vous frappez à la porte de quelqu'un, il
pourrait se fâcher contre vous pour l'avoir exposé
au coven
et si vous essayez de recruter
des volontaires, bonne chance au milieu d'une
pandémie,
nous sommes donc passés à un
modèle d'organisation totalement virtuel
où nos organisateurs travaillent virtuellement le
les chefs d'équipe de bénévoles du quartier
travaillent virtuellement et ils recrutent
des bénévoles virtuels grâce à
l'organisation virtuelle
[Musique]
les gens seront plus réactifs
s'ils reçoivent une invitation personnelle
à venir à un événement qu'ils ne le sont lorsqu'ils
voient une publication sur Facebook
ou qu'ils '  sont plus susceptibles s'ils savent que des
amis vont venir à un
événement,
beaucoup de ces choses ont un impact important
sur notre capacité à faire passer notre message
[Musique] [
Musique]
devrait être
[Musique] le
leadership commence par l'écoute et
les démocrates  à tous les niveaux
écoutent très attentivement les
experts en santé publique, les médecins à la
recherche
et aussi les électeurs et en ce moment, ils
disent tous la même chose
qui est de rester virtuellement concentré sur le
contrôle de
cette pandémie l'engagement fondamental
est de garder les gens en sécurité
[Musique  ]
toi